[Applause]
this is cancellation corner I don't know
you but that outfit tells me you got a
Blog that I'm worried about reading
she'll end my career is this how white
women feel when they see black dudes on
the same side of the street cuz I saw
her y'all saw I saw her and I was like
nope not doing that okay let's be
careful around Eat Pray Love let's not
do that I'm sure you love India hope you
continue to love Indians after show are
you with him or are you alone you're
with him okay thank God all right cuz if
you came alone I would feel like like
you know what I mean you're like
Espionage of some kind where do you work
you're a hair stylist oh okay that's way
better hair stylist you have to be
stylist so that explains that but when I
saw the kind of Indian Shaw I thought
you were one of you know the armpit hair
types and I don't have a problem with
them they just tend to have a problem
with me so that's that's all I was
saying and I didn't mean that to say
you're not beautiful you're a beautiful
woman okay this guy is lucky you look
about like me neither one of us should
have goodlooking girlfriends I'm going
to be honest with
you sometimes I'll be looking at my wife
like this [__] dumb I think cuz there's
no reason this what a dummy dude are you
okay sir I think you might kill me in
any given
moment that's crazy right this is crazy
this is terrifying and I hope you don't
think it's racial it's
this and I just saw that was a sling of
some kind so before I saw you doing
this to be honest if you were white that
would have been much scarier I'd have
been like this is it for all of us this
is an odd energy to bring to a comedy
show
is I'm just going to assess what's
happening I'm not going to laugh you're
fighting the laugh why are you doing
that to both of us you're hurting both
of us your soul wants to be joyful right
now and you're like yo [__] you Soul
keep that [__] in locked in th life
you're not even a thug you're too
handsome and well-dressed to be a thug
dog you're three points to a attractive
and you got two nice of a beanie jacket
combo there's no Thug in you got a job
that pays at least 80,000 a year smile
about it who is this with you may I ask
that ma'am he's probably not going to
answer I'm going to be honest you're
being stubborn at a certain point you're
being stubborn how do you know this man
no comment no
comment is that because he won't allow
you to speak
or you came here with Cruel Intentions
sir I feel like you asked like I want to
be the most well-lit audience member I
want other people to think it's funny
and then look at him and be like maybe
it's not
funny you know what is going to annoy me
is you're going to laugh when I'm not
looking and I'm going to catch you when
it happens I'm going to point you
out there it is there it
[Applause]
is that's